on vous a montré ces images là dans le
but un sport la fin de semaine dernière
des images de ce golfeur québécois quand
on n'est pas prêt d'oublier
c'est son troisième trou d'un coup à vie
mais le plus spectaculaire ou au tournoi
american express en californie à cette
semaine d'autant plus grandiose ans que
ce golfeur n'a qu'un seul bras laurent
hurtubise est avec nous ce matin sur
tubize bonjour bonjour je vois bien très
bien
et vous comment vous gérez votre
notoriété c'est un tourbillon de positif
écoutez les
les demandes ne cessent d'arriver mais
c'est vraiment extraordinaire ce qui
m'arrive
puis je je je veux en profiter pour dire
que dans les prochains jours je met sur
pied avec mes comptable aimé fiscaliste
la fondation leur art tubize pour le
sport c'est les handicapés oui oui
racontez-nous là vous faites du sport
depuis toujours vous êtes né avec un
handicap mais ça vous a jamais freiné
non du tout quand j'ai commencé et quand
j'étais jeune à 6 ans j'ai dit à mes
parents que je voulais jouer au hockey
et ils m'ont dit oui a pas de problème
voisions va t'acheter des patins mon
père faisait une patinoire dans la cour
arrière puis je me suis mis à jouer aux
quilles apprécié jouer au baseball jeter
receveur et je rêve un jour je me disais
que j'aurais pu être la recevoir de jim
abbott qui était un agent d'une main et
c'est simple quand j'ai commencé à jouer
au golf en 11 ans b je mettais mon sac
sur mon épaule droit tous les matins je
m'en allais à vélo club de golf à
chambly mes parents m'avaient rentrée
membres juniors au 7 août à 75 dans
l'europe y jeter là tous les jours avec
mes amis pourquoi l'école faut caser
fait choix laissé ce talent mais parce
que c'est un sport individuel où je
pouvais prouver et démontrer à mes amis
que je t'ai aussi bon que dans ce que je
faisais
malgré mon handicap j'avais montré la
fête se passe extraordinaire
racontez-nous comment vous vous êtes
retrouvé en californie participer
assez à ce tournoi en fait ce programme
là existent depuis longtemps et moi j'ai
joint 2011-2012 dans le dernier tour je
ne me reconnais classique qui est un
programme ou si pékin le tournoi cessé
d'exister ans après la saison 2012
je me suis dit j'aimerais bien trouver
un tournoi où on peut jouer avec des
professionnels pendant le tournoi
et là j'ai trouvé le human challenge qui
était l'ancien babeau classés alors je
me suis inscrit et j'ai payé il ya un
frais à payer et je commence à jouer
là-dedans c'est ma septième année que je
jouais là vous avez joué avec des
professionnels ou et on joue pendant le
tournoi les trois premières rondes avec
un professionnel pendant que lui joue
pour une bourse d'un point 7 millions
nous on joue pour faire un trou d'un
coup
le trou dans le coup est arrivé c'est
votre troisième avis oui mon troisième
avis mon premier sur le circuit mais
c'était à mon 13e trou qui était le
quatrième trou du deuxième neuf et quand
j'ai j'ai installé ma base sur les tiges
et je me suis dit regarde jamais passé
hambourg les patates ait un bon swing
1106 et sl oui mais mon caddie m'avait
mis en confiance tant mieux encore un
humain me dis leur instinct fassis
parfait pour toi edit ajouté petit à
petit chat de gauche à droite les 10
alouettes parfait il faut 4 940 243
verges et d'avoir roulé je me suis
installé puis quand j'ai levé la tête la
balle est à mi-chemin a commencé à
couper de gauche à droite de droite à
gauche
là on la regardait tout sur les noms
entendu le petit pink blond entendu les
gens criaient l'autre bout pendant une
demie selon après l'on a réalisé la tête
dedans juste est surélevé on voyait mal
et le rester c'était fou était médecin
et après qu'est ce que c'est passer des
appels des médias d'un peu partout
le tout d'après ce tapis djetou radio
qui m'attendait
ensuite de ça
j'ai eu des appels pourra être fait ce
thème avec un bagout x à tsn avec gino
chouinard la tva le vendredi matin
s'arrête pas là assis que je me suis
pour une agence de presse qui gère les
demandes qu'on en termine en vous allez
fondez vous allez ouvrir une fondation
we pour inciter les personnes
handicapées à faire du sport sur les
aides et monde et herman si si ils ont
besoin d'un bon état et les motiver en
parlant avec eux et en leur montrant les
possibilités qui s'offrent à eux et
c'est un super exemple mais je suis
merci beaucoup de nuls merci beaucoup